in this video you're going to learn how
to do composition of functions and we're
going to go through four examples
together so let's dive in the first
thing you want to be aware of is this a
different way of writing the composition
of functions sometimes you'll see it as
F of G ofx with this little circle here
and this is equivalent to this notation
F of G ofx I prefer the second notation
because it's a little bit more
descriptive as far as working from the
inside out like we normally do when we
think of the order of operations with
parentheses or you might see it like
this G of F ofx and you can write it as
this G of f ofx so when you see it in
this notation it's kind of like you're
working from the right to the left
whereas here you're working from the
inside out I'll show you what I mean so
in this first example we're working with
f ofx and g ofx these two functions and
we're going to find out what is f of G
of two now what that means is we're
going to go to our G function whatever
is in parentheses that's going to go in
for X on the right side of the equation
so whatever's in the parentheses that's
like our new x value so what we have
here is we have uh 2 s + 3 * 2 + 1
that's what this quantity G of 2 is
equal to so that's actually let's see 4
+ 6 is 10 + 1 is 11 so what we have now
is what's F of 11 so we're going to go
to our F function whatever is in
parentheses we're going to put that in
for X on the right so now we have 11 so
2 * 11 is 22 - 1 is 21 so you can see
what this is It's like a 2ep process or
I like to sometimes call it a double
substitution you're starting from the
inside and you're saying I'm
substituting two into my G function and
I'm getting an answer and that answer
then goes into my f function and so what
composition of functions do is like
they're doing two
operations and you can even have three
functions four functions Etc let's look
at the next one we've got G of f of two
so here what you can see is we're
starting with our F function and we're
putting two in for X so we have 2 * 2 is
4 - 1 is 3 so this quantity here is f of
2 is equal to 3 now if we take three and
we put that into our G function in place
of X what do we get we get 3^ 2ar + 3 *
3 + 1 so that's 9 + 99 + + 1 which is
19 and notice here we got 21 here we got
19 so the order is very important when
you do composition of functions now
these problems usually students can
tackle pretty well but what gets a
little bit trickier here is when we're
trying to write a function in terms of X
using this composition so here what
we're doing is f of G ofx let's start by
rewriting this in my preferred form this
F of G ofx form here so we're going to
say well what what is g of X well G of X
is this whole quantity right here x^2 +
3x +
1 so let's put that in place of G ofx
and now whatever's inside the
parentheses here just like we said
that's going to go in for X on the right
side of the equation so this is actually
equal to 2 time this whole quantity x^2
+ 3x +
1 minus
one okay so now if we simplify what do
we get we're going to distri rute the 2
so that's going to give us
2x^2 + 6 x + 2 -1 or we could write this
as 2x^2 + 6x + 1 so that's what F of G
of X is equal to right here now you
might be saying Mario what's the
significance of that well see how here
we had F of G of2 and we did it in two
steps well say if we were to put two
right in here for X we're going to get
two squ is 4 * 2 is 8 + 6 * 2 is 12 + 1
you can see we're getting 21 which is
the same thing we got over here it's
just that now we have a function that
will do it all in one step for us
instead of having to do substituting
first in for G and then taking that
answer and then substituting in for F
this equation is going to do it all in
one go so to speak so let's look at this
one here G of f ofx so again I like to
rewrite this in my preferred notation
not it's not mine it's just a different
way of writing it and then f ofx is
equal to 2x -1 so let's put that in
place of F
ofx and now remember the way functions
work is whatever is inside of the
parentheses here goes in for X on the
right it's kind of like saying this you
know X is like the input right or the
independent variable so we're saying H
this is our input that's what we're
putting in for X on the right so instead
of X okay instead of x X we're putting
this quantity in for X so this is going
to be 2x - 1^ 2
plus 3 * 2x -1 + 1 now all we have to do
is just a little bit of arithmetic 2x -1
* 2x
-1 if you foil that out let's here let's
actually write it out twice because
sometimes this is a little confusing for
students so it's a binomial times a
binomial here we can just distribute the
three so that's going to give us
6x - 3 + 1 here we have to foil or
distribute twice so we get let's see 4x^
2ar -
2x - another 2x +
1 + 6x - 3 + 1 okay so let's combine
like terms starting with our highest
power we've got
4x^2 we've got a -2X and -2X that's -4x
+ 6 x is
2X and we have 1 + 1 is 2 - 3 is
-1 and that's our G of f ofx now again
let's take a look G of f of2 we got 19
we had to do this in two steps first
putting into the F function taking that
answer and putting it to the G function
let's put it all into this one and see
if it'll do it in one go for us so 2^2
is 4 * 4 is 16 + 2 * 2 is 4 that's 20 -
1 is 19 you can see we're getting the
exact same answer it's just that with
the composition here we can do multiple
operations by using this function as
opposed to having to do it in two steps
so that's kind of the difference between
when you're like evaluating at a
particular number as opposed to using
like an algebraic expression like we did
here so if you want to see more examples
and you want to test yourself which I
recommend follow me over to to another
video I did right there talking about
composition of functions pause the video
try some of those on your own and I'll
see you over in that video